[Music]
i don't mean to be rude but we will wait
for an hour to see your boss
i'm sorry sir but you didn't have an
appointment we didn't have an
appointment cause every time i called
you put me on hold
i'm sure dr hodges will see you as soon
as he can
so what do you want to do hello i guess
we just got to be patient and wait
screw it excuse me sir you can't just
all right here's the deal
my kid's got a damn ulcer cause of you
so either you take him seriously
or you're gonna be taking me seriously
yes sir janice why don't you send little
boy in
right away
he'll see you now
you're at moon pit
and here near apogee we gimble the
engine to exert a torque
that executes a pitch over maneuver to
flip the rocket by 180 degrees
wow that's very impressive thank you
very much for taking the time i'm not
done
oh uh sorry needless to say
we use a pid controller to minimize the
dispersions to the landing site
anything else yes i'd like a glass of
water it's time to take my xantec
you've been in there quite a while well
if the topic is science it can be a real
chatty patty
poor me too hey
someday somebody's gonna write a book
about sheldon don't you want there to be
a chapter about how
loving and supportive you two were
doesn't matter i ain't reading it
this is groundbreaking work thank you
and
and i thought you might want to
apologize
why you tried to shut me up with a patch
well i give those to everyone and and
you have to understand
sheldon that while your math is is
theoretically correct
we don't have the technical capability
to execute it
so i'm ahead of my time well
it would appear so all right call me
when you catch up okay
we can go now
[Music]
for the first time spacex has
successfully landed its falcon 9 rocket
on a drone ship
in the atlantic ocean
spacex founder elon musk called the
event an incredible milestone in the
history of space
elon the cnn reporters here to talk to
you hang on
send them in
[Music]
[Music]
so